how crazy was
off the court
2000 Clippers 2001 Clippers were y'all
hitting the club all the time all the
time I was like the kind of the leader
we used to go to the hotel we used to
get to the hotel and meet me downstairs
we'd just be out every city y'all were
in you guys returning don't just turn it
out wow you know every every Studio
who was like your number one like uh
partner in crime it would be me Jeff
McGinnis
D mouse Q shot we was we used to always
hang tight off the court even the dudes
that didn't we really even like each
other I think I was kind of like the
bridge you kind of like bridged
everybody that kind of glue yeah damn
I can imagine Dairy Smiles Lamar Odom I
mean we all in L.A
you know everybody got like a little man
I was in their pocket mm-hmm
oil into the shame [ __ ] everybody's been
to the sneakers and girls and same [ __ ]
that we entered now yeah
um but it was new it was new to you back
then yeah yeah out straight out of high
school or college wherever he was at
yeah
Dairy Smiles got drafted out of high
school right High School yeah damn so
was he even 18.
or was he like he just turned 18 right
so you're just and I was in 1920 I was
21. you guys weren't even old enough to
drink we was everywhere and the clubs or
just doing Hotel parties Hotel parties
yeah crazy I don't know
so in the club in the club yeah I ain't
the NBA experience to party in your
hotel
we was out
I Can Only Imagine
that era had to be so much more fun
because you have so much less [ __ ] to
worry about there's social media
ownership wasn't out so you could you
could [ __ ] off and like truly [ __ ] off
and not worry about being on tnz the
next day or Twitter or whatever the [ __ ]
it is you can have fun you can have
innocent fun and not have to worry about
being on TMG because you can like not do
anything you could just be out at a club
and like I just saw you I'm sure you saw
they they posted a video of LeBron
gambling and they're trying to make it
like a bad thing because he was playing
Blackjack I'm like who gives a [ __ ]
exactly like he's just you know what I'm
saying yeah like you gotta watch your
back
over everything now